- Dear candidate,
we usually only hire
people with stellar GPAs.
Yours is obviously not that great,
so why do you think you even
ever chance of working here?
You're a young graduate,
fresh out of university.
How will you be able to add
value to a senior client?
You do not seem to have done much
beyond your academic achievements.
So are you just a boring person?
Has any of you ever had a
question in an interview
which really made you uncomfortable?
So this is something that some people
like to call a stress interview.
So an interview where
your interview partner
deliberately tries to
put you under stress.
In this video I will talk about
stress interview situations,
how you can prepare yourself.
The framing of this video
is stress interviews in
job interview situations,
but of course you might also face
stress interviews in other instances.
For instance, when you're
facing a hostile client,
which might ask you questions
that put you under stress.
So welcome to another
video on Firm Learning,
my name is Heinrich.
I'm a former McKinsey consultant
and on my channel I try to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
The video will be structured
in the following ways.
So first I will provide a bit of context
on stress interviews.
So do these really happen?
Is this what you need to expect
when you sit in a consulting interview,
or maybe also in an interview
for another type of role or
position in another company.
And then I will share
three tips or reflections
of how I think about stress interviews
and what you can do to prepare
and handle these
situations in the best way.
So let's first talk about the context.
Does this really happen?
Will you need to sit in a stress interview
when you apply to consulting?
And here, the good thing for you
is actually that many firms
have policies to not do this.
So I know, at least for
Germany, that the MBB firms,
so McKinsey, BCG, and Bain,
usually do not do job interviews
for their interview situations.
But of course the truth is
also that interview cultures
differ by region and
of course also by firm.
So it might be that in some firms
you are facing these situations,
and for sure, outside of consulting,
there are firms where
this is taking place.
So you better be prepared,
because even for MBB firms,
often especially the
later stage interviews
are conducted by partners
or senior partners
and they do have some flexibility
of how to conduct these interviews.
So I would never be sure
that this is not something
that might happen to you as well,
so better be prepared for this.
So what is the why?
Why am I people decide to do that?
Why is anybody putting you
in such a stress situation at all?
And here it might be helpful for you
just to take a step back.
Think about what these interviews
are trying to test after all anyway.
And I would argue that
the number one question
that consulting firms want to
answer when they interview you
is is this person able
to potentially next week
be with me on a team at a client?
Potentially very early on,
in the first one, two, or three weeks,
sit alone with a client, in a
room, having a conversation.
Will this person be
able to handle it well,
to represent the firm well?
This is the main question that consultants
will ask themselves when
interviewing candidates,
in case interviews, in
personal fit interviews,
and any other conversations
that are taking place during interviews.
And here, this is just the truth,
that in a client environment,
if you are a consultant,
you will face stressful situations
where clients would try to go after you,
will try to attack you,
will try to put you under stress.
Situations like this literally happen
every single week on most projects.
You will regularly sit together
in meetings with clients
where these clients might have
a different agenda than you have.
Maybe they don't like the project.
Maybe they have a general
bias against consultants.
Maybe they don't like you.
And they will take
everything that they find
to make you look bad in front of others,
to put you in a stressful situation,
to question your competence,
to question your work results.
And of course, this is not
only the case as a consultant,
but things like that happen
in almost every company.
This is what is called
politics after all, right?
But I would argue that as a consultant
you're a little bit more
prone to situations like this
compared to other people
who are just regular
employees of that company.
Now to close the circle, right?
This is the reason why this
might be tested in interviews.
Interviewer might be
interested to see how you react
if somebody tries to
put you under pressure.
So this is why it's done,
this is why it's tested.
And this is now a great
transition to my three reflections
and tips on how to handle the situations.
And my one tip is to
understand the intention.
Why are people doing this?
Because many candidates,
if you are in an interview
situation with them,
and this is happening to them,
they feel personally attacked.
They feel like, oh, this
interviewer does not like me.
Apparently this interviewer
doesn't want to hire me.
And they instantly get nervous,
getting defensive, and so on.
But this is of course not the intention
in almost all of these situations.
In the vast majority
of cases you can assume
your interviewer to be a
professional after all.
Because if you think about it,
the fact alone that you are
sitting in the interview
means that you passed the
first screening, right?
So the CV screening.
So clearly your CV is considered
good enough to work in this company.
So if any interviewer is
implying that maybe your GPA,
just to pick this example,
is not good enough for the job,
obviously he or she cannot be serious
because otherwise you wouldn't have been
invited to the interview
if your CV would not have
been good enough on paper.
So tip number one, understand this.
This is not about an attack,
but it's a test.
Understand the intention
of why this is happening.
Now my second reflection is on what to do.
So how should you respond to that?
And here I say that even more important
than what exactly you
say is how you say it.
Many people who get such a question
will instantly turn defensive.
They will be nervous,
they suddenly will start
to speak much faster.
Their head will turn
red, and so on, right?
And of course I understand
that this is very difficult,
and especially in a stress situation
than an interview per se already is,
then you're facing such a thing,
it's really difficult to control yourself.
But the first step to improve
is to at least intellectually understand
what you should avoid.
And for sure, do not be defensive.
Do not perceive this to be an attack,
but rather try to
continue the conversation
in the very same tone of voice,
in the very same body posture,
just as you behaved before
this question was asked.
Because after all,
this is exactly what ideally
you would be able to do
in front of a client as well.
You don't want the
conversation to escalate
into any real direction,
whenever you get a comment
that potentially catches you off guard.
You want to be perceived as
handling this professionally,
as finding a very calm and
to the point answer to that
and not instantly getting nervous.
And this is exactly the confidence
that you should at least try to radiate.
So if you are able to do this
this is almost already everything
that then the interviewer
will be looking for.
And then of course,
try to also say a couple
of things that make sense.
Now, again, the GPA example,
when somebody is accusing you
of the GPA not being good enough.
You can just say that,
yes, you acknowledge that
potentially other people
might have higher GPAs
but you still believe that you have
other things that you
can bring to the table.
Then maybe you can mention a
couple of other achievements
in your academic life or
in other areas of your life
that from your perspective
might compensate for that.
Again, I strongly hold
that what exactly you say
isn't even that important,
but rather how you say it.
But before we jump into it
I want to introduce it to
the sponsor of today's video.
And this sponsor is Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people.
You can explore new skills,
deepen your passions,
and get lost in creativity.
There are classes on marketing,
personal branding,
presentations skills, and many more.
All of these are topics
that are highly applicable
to a career in consulting,
banking, or corporate.
And the best thing is that I made
a slide writing class for Skillshare.
So you can access and enjoy
it as a Skillshare member.
Personally, I recently took the class
productivity master class:
principles and tools to
boost your productivity
from the fellow YouTuber, Ali Abdael.
It's a great class,
it taught me many new
aspects of productivity
and I very much enjoyed how he
applied the Pareto principle,
or the 80-20 rule, to productivity.
Classes on Skillshare are
specifically curated for learning.
There are no ads,
they're always launching
new premium classes,
so you can stay focused
and follow wherever your
creativity takes you.
And the best thing is that
it's less than $10 a month
with an annual subscription.
Skillshare created a special offer
for subscribers of this
channel, Firm Learning.
And so the first 1000 subscribers of me
that click on the Skillshare
link in the video description
will get a free trial of the
Skillshare premium membership.
I hope this helps you to
explore your creativity,
check it out, link in
the video description.
Now my third tip is practice,
because the number one reason
why usually seasoned
consultants will be quite good
at defending comments like this
in client situations and so on
is not because are geniuses
or super great at this from the beginning,
but because they already
experienced situations like this
in a very, very frequent way.
And if this happened to you lots of times
then it's not even a
big deal to you anymore.
You know how to handle it,
you know how to reply.
And the very same thing is
true for job interviews.
So if you never thought
that this might happen,
how you would react,
if you've never experienced
anything like this,
of course will be extremely difficult then
to react and reply in the
right and correct way.
So my tip would be that
you try to expose yourself
to these kinds of situations.
So of you still have a couple of years
before you really apply,
try to get yourself into
a leadership position,
into an operational role,
maybe at an organization,
at a social cause that
you really care about
at your university.
Try to get some things done there.
Collect some leadership experience
because in these settings
you might also face situations like this,
where maybe people attack you,
have another agenda than you.
And this is a great playground
just to develop these skills.
If this is now already too late
and now you're really
just a couple of days,
weeks, or months before the interview,
then maybe try to role
play these situations
with another person,
where he or she deliberately
asks you questions like this
and then you try to respond.
And then another way how
you can practice this,
probably especially applicable
for introverts like myself,
is rather to play around
these situations in your head.
So try to imagine sitting in
such an interview situation.
Think about some questions
that the other person
might ask you that will
really catch you off guard,
and think about how you would react.
How your blood pressure
and pulse would increase,
how you will feel uneasy,
not really comfortable.
How you would feel scared,
that maybe this is now
the end of your interview.
Try to really visualize all this
and then try to relax and think about
how you could find a good answer to that.
I'd argue that if you really mentally
go over these situations in a regular way
this will also potentially help you
to handle these situations all right
in an actual setting in an interview.
So I'd love to hear from you now.
Did you ever experience
difficult situations like this,
in job interviews
or when sitting with clients
or other business partners?
Let me know in the comments,
I'd love to hear from you.
I will do my very best to
answer every single comment.
And of course,
comments also help me with
the YouTube algorithm.
So if you took any value
out of this video at all
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And also subscribe to this channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
I'm releasing weekly videos,
every single Saturday.
I also have an Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning.
So check that out as well
if you're interested to see more from me.
And I'd also want to say thanks again
to the sponsor of this video, Skillshare.
So check out the link to Skillshare
in the video description
for this free trial period.
And of course, as always,
a big thank you to the
members of Firm Learning.
You're really helping the
cause of this channel.
So thank you so much for your support.
So again, next video will
come out next Saturday.
So thank you all, have a good weekend.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Cheers.